I went to her lodging to see her, and she sent for wine, and she told me that we would soon drink wine in Paris. It seemed to me a gift from heaven that she was there, and that I was seeing and hearing her. She left Selz on Monday at the hour of Vespers, alongside a great body of armed men. I saw her mount her horse, arrayed all in white armour, with only her head bare and holding a small axe. The great black charger was very restive at her door and would not let her mount. Lead him, she said, to the cross which is in front of the church. And there she mounted, the horse standing still as if he had been bound. Then, turning towards the church which was close by, she said in a beautiful, feminine voice,
我到她的住处去看她，她叫人送来酒，并告诉我，我们很快就能在巴黎共饮。她能在那里，而我能亲眼见到她、亲耳听到她的声音，这对我来说简直是上天的恩赐。她于周一晚祷时分离开塞尔兹，随行的是一大群武装人员。我看着她骑上马，身穿全套白色盔甲，只有头部裸露，手里拿着一把小斧头。那匹巨大的黑色战马在门口非常不安，不让她骑上去。她说，把它牵到教堂前的十字架那里去。她在那里上了马，马站着不动，就像被拴住了一样。然后，她转向旁边的教堂，用优美而女性化的声音说道：
You priests and people of the church, make processions and prayers to God for us. Then, turning to the road, forward, forward, she said. Her unfolded standard was carried by a page. She had her small axe in her hand, and by her side rode a brother who had joined her eight days before. So that's a letter written on the 8th of June 1429 by a soft, tender-hearted young nobleman, Guida Laval, he's writing to his mother, and he is pumped. He is so full of excitement because he has just seen the heroine of the hour, Joan of Arc.
你们这些神职人员和教会的子民，请为我们举行游行并向神祈祷。然后，她转向大路，说道，前进，前进。她那展开的旗帜由一名侍从拿着。她手里拿着那把小斧头，身边骑着一位八天前才加入她的兄弟。这就是1429年6月8日由一位温柔、心肠软的年轻贵族吉达·拉瓦尔写的一封信，他写给他的母亲，他非常激动。他充满了兴奋，因为他刚刚见到了当下的女英雄，圣女贞德。
And Dominic, how beautifully you conveyed her feminine voice there. Thank you. I'm glad you enjoyed that. It's so she'd been brought back to life. So a month has gone by since this extraordinary moment in the history of France and French military achievements at the Liberation of Orleans. So to remind listeners, O'Leon had been under siege for six months by the English, it had been on the verge, it seemed of surrender. Had the English taken it, they would have been able to cross the river Loire and advance deep into south central France. But in the nick of time, the siege had been broken, the English had been driven back, and the banner of the House of Valois, the ancient line of French kings, still. flies over O'Leon.
多米尼克，你刚才传达她那女性化的声音真是太美妙了。谢谢。很高兴你喜欢。这就像她又活过来了一样。距离法国历史上和法国军事成就中这一非凡时刻——奥尔良解放——已经过去一个月了。提醒一下听众，奥尔良当时被英国人围困了六个月，看起来已经到了投降的边缘。如果英国人占领了它，他们就能跨过卢瓦尔河，深入法国中南部。但在千钧一发之际，围困被打破，英国人被击退，瓦卢瓦王朝——法国古老的国王世系——的旗帜依然在奥尔良上空飘扬。
So Tom, various people have taken some credit for this achievement, and you can take us through them, but of course, one above all is the subject of this podcast. Yes, so various French captains, as you said, had definitely played their part in this great drama.
汤姆，不同的人都对这一成就居功，你可以带我们了解一下他们，但当然，其中最重要的一位就是本期播客的主题。是的，正如你所说，几位法国将领确实在这场伟大的戏剧中发挥了作用。
So there was Jean, the bastard of O'Leon, illegitimate half-brother of the Richard Duke of O'Leon, who was languishing in the Tower of London, had been there ever since the Battle of Agin. Corps where he'd been captured. You know, he is, his team aureon on the scene, very battle-hardened, very shrewd, very well connected, despite the fact he's illegitimate.
有奥尔良的私生子让，他是理查德·奥尔良公爵的私生同父异母兄弟，理查德自阿金库尔战役被俘后就一直被关在伦敦塔。你知道，他是现场的奥尔良队，久经沙场，非常精明，尽管他是私生子，但人脉非常广。
He's cousin to the French king, to Charles Vént. Then there's Etienne de Vignolle, better known as Lair, the wrath of God, man of very humble origins, had his legs crushed by a chimney of a pub falling on top of it, but still very feared, very charismatic, the great warlord of his day. And then there is this guy, Gilles de Ray, a Breton nobleman with a particular taste for guerrilla warfare. And Gide Lavelle knew him very well because Gie's brother was married to the daughter of Schilder Ray. Yeah. And there's another side to Gilles-Dor-Rae, isn't there, which we perhaps won't go into
他是法国国王查理七世的堂兄弟。还有艾蒂安·德·维尼奥勒，也就是著名的拉伊，上帝的愤怒，出身非常卑微，双腿曾被倒塌的酒吧烟囱压碎，但依然令人畏惧，非常有魅力，是他那个时代伟大的军阀。还有这个人，吉尔·德·雷，一位对游击战有特殊嗜好的布列塔尼贵族。吉达·拉瓦尔非常了解他，因为吉尔的兄弟娶了吉尔·德·雷的女儿。是的。吉尔·德·雷还有另一面，不是吗？我们可能不会马上深入探讨，但那可能是他名声上的一个污点。我们以后可能会谈到这一点。总之，当时吉尔·德·雷或其他任何法国将领的盾徽上都没有污点，因为在奥尔良奇迹之后，他们开始认为自己是战友，他们现在有一种不可思议的魅力，这就是吉达·拉瓦尔加入他们的原因。他自己也想分一杯羹。他想加入这个兄弟连。然而，这些军阀、这些将领中，没有一个人能像她那样最迷人、最激动人心、最体现奥尔良奇迹。不是那个私生子，不是拉伊，
immediately, but perhaps it's a shadow over his reputation. We may be coming to that in due course. anyway, but at the time, there is no blot on the escutcheon of Gilles-Dor-Rae or any of the other French captains, because in the wake of the miracle of Alleyon, they have come to think of themselves as brothers in arms, and they have an incredible glamour now, and this is why Gidea Laval has joined them. He wants a bit of it himself. He wants to join this band of brothers. However, none of these warlords, none of these captains, is the person who most, most glamorously, most stirringly, embodies the miracle of All Neon. It's not the bastard, it's not Lair,
不是吉尔·德·雷，而是一个十几岁的女孩。吉达·拉瓦尔在向母亲描述这个人时所表现出的那种虔诚精神，让人能感受到她的魅力。是的，我看着她骑上马，身穿全套白色盔甲，只有头部裸露，手里拿着一把小斧头。在这里，你可以感受到15世纪流行的亚瑟王骑士传奇的影响。我的意思是，她实际上就像他们喜爱的一本书、吟游诗人唱的故事或歌曲中的人物活过来了一样，不是吗？是的。当然，这就是圣女贞德。令人震惊的是，就在几个月前，她还是一个穿着粗布衣服的农家女。
it's not Gilles de Re, it's a teenage girl. And the sense of her charisma is palpable in the spirit of devotion with which Gidea LaValle has described this person to his mother. Yes, I saw her mount her horse, arrayed all in white armour, with a little bit of her. only her head bear and holding a small axe. And you can sense here the influence of the kind of Arthurian chivalric romances that were so popular in the 15th century. I mean, she's effectively, it's as though one of the books that they love, one of the stories or the songs that Trubedores sing has come to life, isn't it? Yeah. So this, of course, is Joan of Arc. And it's absolutely astonishing that only months before, you know, she'd been a peasant in a kind of homespun
而现在，她就像兰斯洛特一样。她把自己变成了一种骑士精神的化身。她赢得了这些久经沙场的男人们的心和钦佩。所以，你知道，私生子、拉伊、吉尔·德·雷。你知道，这太令人震惊了。她之所以能做到这一点，是因为她非常勇敢。她表现出了巨大的热情。她表现出了巨大的、一种真正理解击败英国人、解除围困需要什么的意识。但我认为她也体现了一些完全特殊的东西，因为圣女贞德在中世纪历史的整个进程中都是一个例外。这是一种本能的展示和形象天才。她就像是打了类固醇的中世纪大卫·鲍伊。她明白
dress. And now she is like Solonsalot. She's transformed herself into a kind of flower of chivalry. And she's won the hearts and the admiration of these very battle-hardened men. So, you know, the bastard Lair, Gilles de Rey. You know, it's astonishing. And she'd done it because she was very courageous. She'd shown tremendous seal. She'd shown enormous, a kind of, a kind of real sense of what it would take to defeat the English, to relieve the siege. But I think also she embodied something that is completely exceptional, because Joan of Arc, through the entire sweep of medieval history, is someone exceptional. And this is a kind of instinctive genius for display and image. She's kind of the medieval David Bowie on steroids. She understands
如何展示自己？但就这一点而言，对吧？我的意思是，实际上，作为一个女人，泰勒·斯威夫特或Lady Gaga可能是一个很好的类比。但就这一点而言，她不仅在利用
How to Project herself? But just on this, right? I mean, actually, you know, she's as a woman, that's sort of Taylor Swift or Lady Gaga might be as good a parallel. But just on this, she is drawing not just on
宗教肖像画之类的东西，而且她非常清楚地借鉴了骑士传奇的传统。她在扮演一个角色。我的意思是，那场表演的意义，我认为非常重要。她是有意识或无意识地扮演一个人们知道会激励骑士并让他们兴奋的角色
the religious iconography and whatnot, but she is very clearly drawing on the tradition of the chivalry romances. And she's playing a part. I mean, the point of that performance, I think, is really important. She is consciously, or unconsciously, playing a part that people know will inspire nights and get them excited
以及所有这类事情。我的意思是，圣女贞德现象中确实存在一种奇观的成分。是的。我的意思是，我怀疑这不是一种计算。这是她内心深处事物的表达。但我认为，她内心深处的东西受到了她在成长过程中听到的传奇故事的巨大影响。显然，她有骑士梦想。
and all of this sort of stuff. I mean, there is a definite element of spectacle about the Joan of Arc phenomenon. Yeah. I mean, I suspect this isn't kind of, you know, calculation. It's expression of what is in her heart. But what is in her heart has been massively influenced, I think, by the romances that we know that she listened to when she was growing up. And clearly she has dreams of chivalry.
疯狂的是，她不是一个年轻人，而是一个年轻女性。她不仅敢于实现这些梦想，而且还说服了那些顽固的贵族分享这些梦想，把她这个农家女孩看作一位贵族。我已经引用过玛丽娜·华纳的书，她在这一点上非常出色。所以玛丽娜·华纳写道，贞德是流动性的化身。她既不接受她的农民出身，也不接受她的女性身份，不接受社会为她设定的任何限制。相反，在骑士时代，她采用了最成功的伪装，并打扮自己
The mad thing is, is that she's not a young man, she's a young woman. She's not only dared to live these dreams out, but she has persuaded hard-bitten nobleman to share in them, to see her, a peasant girl, as a nobleman. And Marina Warner, whose book I've already cited is brilliant on this. So Marina Warner writes, Joan was the personification of mobility. She accepted neither her peasant birth nor her female condition, none of the limitations. none of the limitations society had provided for her circumscription. Instead, in an age of chivalry, she assumed its most successful guise and dressed herself
表现得像一个天生的骑士。但问题是，当然，她不是骑士。她是一个女人。而且，我的意思是，这就是她的悖论，不是吗？她在扮演一个男性角色，一个传统的男性角色，而且她被男人包围着。但是，我的意思是，她并没有假装自己是男人，对吧？她根本没有抛弃她的女性身份，而是实际上利用了它。而且，正是因为她这样做，这肯定赋予了她某种超自然或神圣力量的一部分，因为她把自己置于传统的性别规范之外。
and comported herself like a knight born to the role. But the thing is, of course, she is not a knight. She's a woman. And, I mean, this is the paradox of her, isn't it? That she's playing a male part, a traditionally male part, and she's surrounded by men. But, I mean, she's not pretending to be a man, right? She doesn't cast off her feminine identity at all, but she actually draws on it. And it's the fact that she is, surely that's what gives her part of the sort of, as well, supernatural or divine power, is the fact that she is setting herself outside the conventional gender norms.
所以人们把她看作一个与众不同的女人。是的。或者说，她正在融合男性和女性最强大的表达方式。所以我们已经说过，她是如何沉迷于骑士精神的表演和魅力中的。但她也本能地理解，女性特别能够引导出深层的精神力量。
So people see her as a woman apart. Yeah. Or she's fusing the most potent expressions of what is male and female. So we've said to how, you know, how she's, she buys into the show. and the glamour of knighthood. But she also instinctively understands that there are deep reserves of spiritual power that women particularly are able to channel.
所以，你知道，她绝对不是跨性别者。她不想改变性别。她从不声称，也从不假装自己是男性。她总是称自己为“贞德，圣女”。她这样做是在利用所有与处女身体相关的传统。是的。
So, you know, she is absolutely not trans. She does not want to change her sex. She never claims she never pretends to be male. She always calls herself Jean-La Pusel, Joan the maid. And what she's doing there is drawing on all the traditions that are associated with the body of a virgin girl. Yeah.
你知道，她将其视为她身份的核心。所以，她在男性可能达到的最尚武的方式上是男性化的，但她在女性可能达到的最神圣的方式上是女性化的。正是这种融合是如此独特，使得贞德在中世纪欧洲历史的进程中成为一个完全特殊的人。所以我们之前几次把她和我们在节目中谈到的另一个人——锡耶纳的凯瑟琳——进行了比较。但锡耶纳的凯瑟琳几乎完全借鉴了女性原型。嗯，她是基督的新娘，不是吗？
You know, she's casting it as the very essence of her identity. And so she is male in the most martial way it's possible to be male, but she is female in the holiest way it is possible to be female. And it's this fusion that is so unique and that makes Joan such a completely exceptional person in the, you know, the sweep of medieval European history. So we compared her before a couple of times to another person we've done on the show, Catherine of Sienna. But Catherine of Sienna draws almost exclusively on kind of female archetypes. Well, she's the bride of Christ, isn't she?
贞德有点不同。在第一集中，你谈到了她对圣迈克尔的痴迷，那种守护神、战士圣人等等。天堂的队长，所有这些，大天使的领袖。而圣迈克尔，我的意思是，你可能会说这是一个非常男性化的形象，但他是吗？因为他有点无定形，不是吗？嗯，他是一个天使，所以他是无性的。对。天使在任何意义上都没有性别。
Joan is a bit different. And in the first episode, you talked about her obsession with St. Michael, the kind of, you know, a patron saint, a warrior saint and so on. the captain of heaven, all of that, the leaders of the archangels. And St. Michael, I mean, you might say a very male figure, but is he? Because he's a little bit amorphous, isn't he? Well, he's an angel, and so he's sexless. Right. Angels do not have sex in any sense.
对。好的。是的。那是一个非常小众的爱好。所以他既不是男性，也不是女性。他有点超越了这一点。正如我们所说，迈克尔已经成为法国抵抗运动的象征，而贞德现在已经成为
Right. Okay. Yeah. That's a very niche, a very niche hobby. And so he's neither male. He's not female. he is kind of more than that. And Michael, as we said, had become the emblem of French resistance, and Joan has now become
法国抵抗运动的象征。虽然我认为贞德的同时代人从未公开进行过这种比较，但在她的战友们反复称她为有吸引力，但从未在他们心中激起性欲的人的方式中，有一种这种无性特征的暗示。所以这是让·德·梅斯，她的侍从，在她死后写的。虽然她是一个年轻的女孩，美丽且身材匀称，当帮助她穿戴盔甲或其他时候，我经常看到她的乳房。虽然有时当我为她包扎伤口时，我看到她的腿完全裸露，而且我多次靠近她。
the emblem of French resistance. And although the comparison, I don't think, is ever overtly made by Joan's contemporaries, there is a hint of this kind of sexless character that they see her as possessing in the way that her companions in arms repeatedly speak of her as someone who is. attractive, but who nevertheless never provoke sexual desire in them. So here is Jean Doulon, her squire, who wrote after she had died. Although she was a young girl beautiful and shapely, and when helping to arm her or otherwise, I have often seen her breasts. And although sometimes when I was dressing her wounds, I have seen her legs quite bare, and I have gone close to her many
在那段日子里，我年轻力壮。尽管我看到或接触过这位圣女，但我的身体从未被激起对她的任何肉欲，她的任何士兵或侍从也没有这样。我认为对于贞德的战友，她的男性战友来说，强调她是一位圣女，她的贞洁是她神圣性的标志，而这种神圣性反过来又是她是她所说的那种人的证据——上帝派来的使者，这一点很重要。对。而且在奥尔良的任何将领中，你知道，当她斥责他们所有这些事情时，当她因为错误的决定而训斥他们时，没有任何迹象表明任何
times. And I was strong, young and vigorous in those days. Never, despite any sight or contact I had with the maid was my body moved to any carnal desire for her, nor where any of her soldiers or squired moved in this way. And I think it's important for Jones' comrades, her male comrades, to emphasize that she is a maid, that her virginity is the marker of her holiness, and that this holiness in turn is the evidence that she is what she says she is, a messenger sent from God. Right. And there's no sense that any of the captains at Orleans, you know, when she's berating them on all of that kind of thing, when she is haranguing them about bad decisions and stuff, there's no sense that any of the
将领怀疑她并说，这个突然冒出来的农家女孩是谁，你知道，她声称是上帝派来的，或者任何骑士或这些人，他们集体选择相信。他们是吗？还是有怀疑论者？当然有怀疑论者。当然，贞德需要时间来说服他们，她所代表的是他们应该接受的东西。但事实胜于雄辩。你知道，她祈祷了，风向变了。她建议应该攻击英国人。他们攻击了英国人。结果成功了。奥尔良解放了。奇迹本身就说明了一切。她完全做到了她说要做的事情。这就是为什么像吉达·拉瓦尔这样的人——我们以他对比贞德的热情描述开始了本期节目——这就是他们买账的原因。你知道，有一种电光火石般的兴奋感，她所说的一切都是真的，上帝站在法国军队这一边，所有看起来可怕的事情现在都被这种光辉、这种荣耀感、这种奇迹感所照亮。这就是吉和许多其他人所买账的东西。我的意思是，这很有趣，因为实际上，贞德对奥尔良的解放是她所创造的唯一奇迹。
captains doubt her and say, who is this flipping jumped up peasant girl, you know, who claims to be sent by God, or any of the knights or any of these people, they collectively, you know, choose to believe. Do they? Or are any skeptics? Of course there are skeptics. And of course, it takes time for Joan to persuade them that what she represents is something that they should be buying into. But the proof is in the pudding. You know, she prayed, the wind changed. She suggested that the English should be attacked. They attacked the English. It works out. Ollian is liberated. The miracle stands for itself. She's done exactly what she said she would do. And this is why people like Guy de Laval, whose kind of enthusiastic
所以在你读的那封信中，吉描述了她的马有点不安，贞德说把它带到十字架那里，然后马就平静下来了，好像那里有奇迹的暗示，但我的意思是，这相当无力。而贞德本人，你知道，她否认了所有这些。
description of Joan we began this show with, that's why they're buying into it. You know, there's this electric sense of excitement that everything she had said was true, that God is on the side of French arms, that everything that would seem terrible has now been raised up in this kind of illumined by this splendor, this sense of glory, this sense of kind of wonder and the miraculous. And that's what Guy and loads of other people are buying into. I mean, it's interesting because effectively Jones' liberation of Orleans is the only miracle that she has performed.
她总是说，这又是她与其他女性远见者，或者实际上是所有远见者之间的一个巨大分歧点。他们都声称有各种各样的奇迹。贞德没有这样做。有很多人希望她成为奇迹创造者，希望她进行奇迹般的治愈等等。
So in that letter that you read, Ghee describes how her horse is a bit frisky and Joan says take it over to the cross and then the horse calms down as though there's a hint of the miraculous there but I mean it's pretty feeble stuff. And Joan herself, you know, she repudiates all this.
她没有。嗯，即使是奥尔良的解围。是的。我的意思是，那并不是真正的超自然奇迹。我的意思是，围困经常被解除。我的意思是，当然，法国人认为他们会输，但实际上他们最终赢了，他们对此感到很高兴。但你不需要诉诸超自然解释来解释为什么他们能够击溃
She always said, and this again is a massive point of difference between her and other female visionaries or indeed, you know, visionaries full stop. They allane claim to all kinds of miracles. Joan doesn't do that. There are lots of people who want her to be a miracle worker who want her to perform miraculous healings or whatever.
英国人。我的意思是，那是……嗯，多米尼克，你不需要。但这就是贞德声称她所创造的那个奇迹。我想你会说，奥尔良的解围是由一个农家女孩完成的，这本身就是一个奇迹。我的意思是，这看起来确实非常令人震惊。
She doesn't. Well, even the relief of Orleans. Yeah. I mean, it's not really a supernatural miracle. I mean, sieges are often relieved. I mean, sure, the French thought they were going to lose and actually they ended up winning and they're delighted by that. But you don't need to resort to supernatural explanations for why they were able to route
人们相信这确实是奇迹。但除此之外真的没有什么了，因为贞德希望焦点完全集中在她从声音那里得到的使命上。对。而那个使命就是解除奥尔良的围困，那是考验。她通过了。
the English. I mean, that's... Well, Dominic, you don't. But that is the one miracle. that Joan says that she has performed. And I guess you would say it was a miracle that the relief of Orlyan was performed by a peasant girl. I mean, that does seem really stunning.
所以她声称自己是上帝派来的，现在被法国这边的基本上所有人广泛接受。尤其是她所服务的那个男人，也就是王储。所以即使是贞德仍然称他为王储，不是吗？每个人都称他为王储，名义上的查理七世，因为他还没有真正成为国王或被接受为国王。所以他击退了英国人，去了兰斯并加冕，因为兰斯距离巴黎东北80英里，在英国控制的领土内，这是几代法国国王加冕的地方。千年了。你需要去那里。而查理已经在那里徘徊了七年。那是他父亲1422年去世，他绝望地希望他能去兰斯并加冕，看起来根本没有任何希望。而贞德不仅向他承诺她会解除奥尔良的围困，而且她会让他去兰斯加冕，并和他一起赶走英国人。所以他现在一定在想，好吧，她完成了第一项。第二项和第三项呢？
And people buy into the fact that that is properly miraculous. But there isn't really anything else because Joan wants the focus to be entirely on the mission that she has been given by her voices. Right. And that mission was to relieve Orleans, and that was the test. And she has passed it.
是的，绝对。在奥尔良解围后的几周里，他确实全力以赴，试图帮助她实现这两个预言。所以被派往奥尔良的救援部队，在城市解围后几乎立即解散了，基本上是因为没有剩下的资金来维持它在战场上。王储的国库是空的。而这又是奥尔良解围奇迹品质的一部分。你知道，尽管王储实际上已经破产，但它还是发生了。在奥尔良解围后，王储现在确信人们会响应他的号召，而不指望得到报酬，因为现在他们会这样做，因为，你知道，他们是在追随一位奇迹般的圣女。上帝，如果他们想战斗而不拿报酬，那真的会是一个奇迹。事实证明确实如此。因为到六月初，大约5000人已经在塞尔兹集结，这是卢瓦尔河以南、图尔和奥尔良之间的一个小镇，其中当然包括吉达·拉瓦尔。所以他有点典型，你知道，他表达了为什么这些人现在准备为
And so her claim to have been sent from God is now widely accepted by, basically, everyone on the French side. Not least, the man that she is serving, who is the dauphin. So even Joan still calls him the dauphin, don't they? Everybody calls him the dofins, the titular Charles the 7th, because he won't really become king or be accepted as king. So he's driven back the English and gone into Grasse and been crowned because Rance, 80 miles northeast to Paris, in English-held territory, this is the place where for generations French, kings have been crowned. millennium. You need to get there. And Charles has been hanging around for seven years. It's the death of his father in 1422, hoping desperately he can get to Reuss and be crowned and there seems no prospect of it whatsoever. And Joan has promised him not only that she will relieve Orleans, but that she will crown him in Reince and drive out the English with him. So he must now be thinking, well, she's done number one. What about number two and number three?
王储而战，以一种他们以前没有过的方式，并且不指望得到报酬。对。事实上，吉达·拉瓦尔为了资助这次竞选，被迫卖掉了土地。所以他不仅没有得到报酬。他实际上，你知道，他还缺几个庄园。现在，在法国的各位贵族和将领中，正如我们在上一集中提到的，有一位从一开始就是贞德的超级粉丝。这就是阿朗松公爵让，他只有20岁，但被王储任命为这支招募的远征军的总司令。贞德本人，尽管她在信中称自己为军队的队长，但她没有正式军衔，但她实际上并不需要一个。
Yeah, absolutely. And in the weeks that follow the relief of Orlyor, he kind of really sets his shoulder to the wheel in an attempt to try and help her fulfill these other two prophecies. So the relief force that had been sent to Orlyor, that had been disbanded almost immediately after the relief of the city, basically because there aren't any funds left to keep it in the field. The Dofans treasury is empty. And that again is part of the miraculous quality of the relief of Orlyor. You know, it's come despite the fact that the dofant effectively is bankrupt. In the wake of the relief of Ornoyor, the dauphin is now confident that men will answer his call and not expect to be paid because now they will do it because, you know, they are following a miraculous virgin. God, that really, that really would be a miracle if they want to fight and not be paid. That is what turns out to be the case. Because by early June, some 5,000 men have assembled at cells, which is this small town south of Loire between Tor and Orleans, and among them, of course, was Guida Laval. So he's kind of typical of, you know, he's expressive of why these people are now ready to fight for
王储指示阿朗松，他在所有事情上都要按照她的建议行事。事实证明，这次战役取得了惊人的成功。贞德的建议再次证明是非常有效的。就像他们在奥尔良受到羞辱一样，现在一系列英国指挥官发现当他们面对贞德时，他们确实处于下风
the Dofé in a way that they hadn't been before and not expect to be paid for it. Right. And in fact, Gidea LaValle, to fund this campaigning, he had been forced to sell lands. So not any is he not being paid. He's actually, you know, he's short of a few estates or two. Now, among the, various nobles and captains of France, as we mentioned in the previous episode, there is one who, right from the beginning, has been a massive Joan fan. And this is the Duke of Alonso, Jean, who's only 20, but has been appointed by the Donofant to serve as commander-in-chief of this expeditionary force that has been recruited. Joan herself, even though in her letters, she described herself as a captain of men, she has no official rank, but she doesn't actually need one.
和她的人。所以，我们应该回顾一下
and the DoFat gives instructions to Alonso that he is to act in all matters by her advice. And as it turns out, the campaign is an amazing success. And Joan's advice, again, turns out to be incredibly effective. And just as they had been humiliated at Alleyon, so now a succession of English commanders find themselves very much coming second best when they come up against Joan. and her men. So let's, should we go through
这些战役吗？首先，这个叫雅尔若的地方，在奥尔良的上游。这是一个桥头堡。萨福克公爵
these campaigns? So first of all, this place called Jaalgo, and that's upriver from Orleans. It's a bridging point. The Duke of Suffolk
在那里，他被法国炮兵打得落花流水，不是吗？是的。他们有一个
is there, and he's there, and he is made a completely battered by French artillery, aren't they? Yeah. They have a,
法国人有一门叫“牧羊女”的轰击炮，是以贞德的名字命名的。而且，你知道，炮兵发挥了作用，堡垒倒塌了，然后贞德和同伴们
the French have a bombard called the Shepardess, which is named after Joan. And, you know, the artillery does its work, the keep collapses, and then Joan and Co.
冲进了城墙。她挥舞着她的旗帜。努力战斗，上帝会与你们并肩作战。上帝已经注定了英国人的命运。英国人最终被俘虏，包括萨福克公爵。这对英国人来说是一个巨大的打击。萨福克公爵表现得非常出色，不是吗？他确实。他很有风度，他封那个俘虏他的人为骑士，我认为这太棒了。或者你可能会说他很势利，因为他不想被一个不是骑士的人俘虏。是的。所以这就是
Storm the city walls. She's waving her, banner. fight hard and God will fight hard with you. God has doomed the English. And the English end up being taken prisoner, including the Duke of Suffolk. So that's a massive blow for the English. And the Duke of Suffolk behaves splendidly, doesn't he? He does. Sportingly, he knights the person who takes him prisoner, which I think is tremendous. Or you might say snobbishly, because he doesn't want to be captured by someone who's not a knight. Yeah. So that's the,
萨福克公爵被俘虏了。当然，他曾是奥尔良的指挥官。但后来对英国人来说有一个更沉重的打击，因为这次轮到塔尔博特了——约翰·塔尔博特，是的，英国伟大的劳伦斯·德拉利奥——被俘虏了，他遭受了惨败，不是在，你知道，他不是在保卫一个城镇，他是在开阔地，这是一场像阿金库尔战役以来英国人一直认为他们注定会赢的那种正面交锋。但现在他们输了。
that's the Duke of Suffolk taken prisoner. And he, of course, had been in command at Orleans. But one later there's an even more crushing blow for the English to to to India because this time it's the turn of Talbot so John Talbot yeah the great Lawrence Delalio of of the English to be taken prisoner and he suffers a crushing defeat not in you know he's he's not he's not defending a town he's in he's in the open and this is a pitched battle of the kind that the English ever since Agincourt have pretty much taken for granted that they are bound to win But now they lose.
2000名英国人被杀。这是他们无法承受的人力损失。但当然，更具破坏性的是，他们失去了这种不可战胜的声誉。而且，你知道，这极大地归功于贞德。她去找王储说，看，我们取得了这两场胜利。你的两个敌人现在是俘虏，萨福克和塔尔博特。显然和你在一起，现在我们必须抓住时机。我们必须推进到卢瓦尔河的安全区之外，我们必须深入敌占区。我们的目标必须是卢瓦尔河以北约130英里处的一个地方
2,000 Englishmen are killed. This is a loss of manpower that they can't really afford. But of course, even more damagingly, perhaps, is the fact that they have lost this reputation for invincibility. And again, you know, this redounds massively to Jones' credit. And she goes to the Dofan and she says, look, we've had these twin victories. Two of your enemies are now prisoner, Suffolk and Talbot. is clearly with you, now we must seize the moment. We must advance beyond the safe zone of the Loire and we must go deep into enemy-held territory. And our target must be a place some 130 miles
超越巴黎。当然，这就是神圣的兰斯城。这是一个非常、非常冒险的行动，原因有二。首先，你知道，它在130英里之外。他们没有时间组织补给车队。由于这个原因，他们必须移动得非常快。而且因为这个原因，因为他们无法携带补给，他们也无法携带炮兵，这意味着他们无法对兰斯进行围攻。
to the north of the Loire beyond Paris. And this is, of course, the holy city of Morance. And this is a really, really sort of dodgy undertaking for a couple of reasons. First of all, you know, it's 130 miles away. They're not going to have time to organize a supply train. They're going to have to move very fast for that reason. And because of that, because they're not going to be able to take supplies, they are going, not going to be able to take artillery either, which means they're not going to be able to lay a siege to her house.
他们不能进行持久的围攻。但正如往常一样，贞德说，哦，上帝会提供的。王储相信她。而上帝确实提供了。因为在7月5日，王储和他的军队带着贞德。他们到达了特鲁瓦的城墙前，这是香槟省的主要城市。当然，这就是王储被他父亲剥夺继承权的地方，根据疯子查理六世与亨利五世和勃艮第公爵签署的和平条约的条款。而勃艮第公爵对这座城市施加了非常强大的影响。
They can't be a protracted siege. But as always, Joan says, oh, God will provide. And the Dofam believes her. And God does provide. Because on the 5th of July, the Doefan his army with Jones. They arrived before the walls of Trois, and this is the principal city of Champagne. And, of course, it is where the dauphin had been disinherited by his father, by the terms of the peace treaty that the lunatic Charles VI had signed with Henry V and the Duke of Burgundy. And the Duke of Burgundy exercises a very strong influence on the city.
议会忠于公爵，忠于好人菲利普。所以当王储出现在城墙前时，国王对这座城市有很强的影响力。议会拒绝投降。但贞德一点也没有被吓倒或退缩。她告诉王储，我的声音告诉我，四天之内，我会带你进入特鲁瓦，尽管正如你提到的，多米尼克，
The council is loyal to the Duke to Philip the good. And so when the dauphin appears before the walls of the city, the city, the king is a very strong influence on the city. the council refuses to surrender. But Joan is not daunted or put off by this at all. And she tells the Dofins, my voices have told me that within four days, I will lead you into Tois, despite the fact, as you mentioned, Dominic,
法国人没有炮兵。那么这到底是怎么发生的呢？所以贞德所做的是，她骑着马绕着城墙走，她命令她的人用灌木丛填满城墙周围的沟渠，而市民们——不是议会成员，而是普通的，你知道，城里的普通人——他们聚集在城墙上，他们往下看，他们看到了贞德
that the French have no artillery. So how on earth is this going to happen? So what Joan does, she rides on her horse round the walls of the city, and she commands her men to fill the ditches that surround the walls with, Brushwood and the townsmen, so not the members of the council, the general, you know, the kind of everyday people in the city, they gather on the walls and they look down and they see Joan
他们看到她的人在堵塞沟渠，他们变得越来越紧张。引用海伦·卡斯特关于贞德的书中的话，经过四天的恐惧和日益加深的不确定性，看到这些由奇迹般的圣女领导的突击准备工作，最终粉碎了城镇的抵抗。所以甚至在贞德和她的部队进攻之前，特鲁瓦的人民就被吓坏了，他们决定投降，并强迫议会这样做。所以正如贞德所预言的那样，王储骑马进入了城市，贞德带着她那面巨大的丝绸白旗和他在一起。所以又是一场巨大的胜利。如果我能暂停叙述一下。所以很明显，出于可以理解的原因，你希望这是一个尽可能迷人、令人兴奋的故事。
and they see her men blocking up the ditches and they get more and more nervous. And to quote Helen Castor in her book on Joan, after four days of fear and deepening uncertainty, the sight of these preparations for an assault led by the miraculous maid finally shattered the town's resistance. So even before Joan and her forces attack, the people of Tuar are so spooked that they've decided to surrender and they force the council to do this. And so just as Joan had prophesied, the Dofair rides into the city and Joan is there with him carrying her great silken white banner. So another tremendous victory. And if I can just pause the narrative for a second. So obviously, for understandable reasons, you want this to be as glamorous and exciting as story as possible.
所以你有点夸大了奇迹般的元素和令人惊叹的胜利，这些胜利只能用贞德非凡的魅力来解释，等等等等。然而，一个怀疑论者可能会说，你实际上泄露了秘密，不是在这个系列中，而是在我们曾经做过的关于百年战争的第一个系列中，
so you are kind of playing up the miraculous elements and amazing triumphs against the odds that are only explicable by Jones' extraordinary charisma and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. However, a skeptic might say that you actually gave the game away, not in this series, but in the very first series we ever did
在那里你非常详尽且令人信服地指出，英国人总是，你知道，法国更富有、更强大、人口更多，所有这些。在某种程度上，英国人在百年战争中所谓的胜利
about the Hundred Years' War, where you pointed out a great length and very convincingly that the English were always, you know, France is richer, more powerful, more populace, all of this. And in a way, the English so-called triumphs in the Hundred Years War
总是虚幻的。你可以争辩说，英国人总是过度扩张，这总是……我的意思是，我记得在过去，当你贬低亨利五世时，你曾经说你认为他是一个糟糕的国王，因为他在法国的战役中极大地扩张了英国
were always a losery. And you could argue that the English were always massively overextended, that it was always... I mean, I remember in the old days, when you used to diss Henry V, he used to say you thought he was a bad king because he hugely extended the England in a campaign in France
从长远来看，他们根本不可能赢，总有一天他们会被赶回去。我想在某种程度上你可以说，当然，贞德对这个故事非常重要。但即使你把她排除在外，你也可以争辩说，这迟早会发生，英国人永远无法守住所有这些领土。他们在人口统计方面被大大超过了。法国，总有一天法国会在某种魅力领袖的领导下团结起来，
they couldn't possibly win in the long run, that one day eventually they would be driven back. And I suppose in a way you could say, Of course, Joan is really important to this story. But even if you take her out of it, you could argue that this would have happened at some point anyway, that the English were never going to be able to hold on to all this territory. They're hugely outnumbered in terms of demography. France, one day France would get its act together under a charismatic leader of some kind,
而这就是这个故事背后的原因。他们是百年战争的地缘政治、战略现实。好吧，所以，我的意思是，对此有两点。第一点是贞德正在改变法国的士气。是的。英国成功的一个关键部分，为什么他们能够统治，当然是法国北部，尽管实际上并没有那么多人，是阿金库尔的神秘感，那种他们不可战胜的感觉。而贞德有效地摧毁了那种神秘感。第二件事，关于特鲁瓦的具体问题以及他们为什么投降，这不是
and that that's what lies behind this story. They're kind of geopolitical, the strategic realities of the Hundred Years' War. Okay, so just, I mean, two points to that. The first is that what Joan is doing is turning the needle on French morale. Yeah. A crucial part of English success, why they have been able to dominate, certainly northern France, despite really not having that many men, is the mystique of Agincourt, the sense that they are invincible. And Joan effectively has destroyed that mystique. The second thing, the specific issue of Toir and why they surrender, it's not.
英国人是特鲁瓦的敌人。是勃艮第公爵。勃艮第人，对。而王储作为勃艮第人的死敌——阿马尼亚克派的代表在那里。所以从这个意义上说，投降确实是，我认为，非凡的，当然也是对贞德神秘感的一种致敬。是的。而且我认为如果忽视她个人在说服特鲁瓦内部的勃艮第分子投降方面所产生的影响，那将是粗鲁的。魅力领袖很重要，但如果你把它想象成一个电子游戏，
the English who are the enemy in Tois. It's the Duke of Burgundy. Burgundian, right. And the Dofant is there as a representative of the bitter, bitter enemy of the Burgundians, the Arminiacs. So in that sense, the surrender really is, I think, extraordinary and a tribute certainly to the mystique of Joan. Yeah. And I think it would be churlish to discount the impact that she personally had in persuading the Burgundian elements within within Trois to surrender. The charismatic leader matters, but if you imagine it as a video game,
作为一个棋盘游戏，法国人最终总是拥有更多的牌。当他们最终弄清楚如何打这些牌时，他们就会赢。我的意思是，我们有点偏离主题了，但我认为，如果奥尔良陷落，如果英国人推进到南部，如果他们占领了布尔日，
as a board game, the French ultimately always have more cards. When they finally work out how to play those cards, they will win. I mean, we're kind of get slightly off-piece here, but I think that had Orly on Fallen, had the English advanced into the south, had they captured Borge,
如果王储逃跑了，如果他们能够对整个法国建立一种非常松散的主权，从长远来看，他们仍然不可能守住法国，法国相对于英国来说太强大了，以至于这种情况永远不会发生。但我确实认为，奥尔良被解围，查理、他的战争队长和聚集在他旗帜下的人们发现，当他们深入英国和勃艮第控制的法国时，实际上一切都分崩离析了。整叠牌都分崩离析了。没有贞德，他们就不会那样做。我的意思是，可能是贞德，我的意思是，她实际上是在虚张声势。但是，你知道，这需要一个不懂战争的农家女孩来做到这一点。这是一个令人震惊的故事。而且我认为，对于她的支持者来说，她是一个极其强大和迷人的人物，这并不奇怪。而对于她的敌人来说，她是一个令人恐惧的人物。一个似乎行使了巫术的人。所以我稍微偏离了叙述。
had the Dauphin fled, had they been able to establish a kind of very loose sovereignty over the whole of France, it would still have been impossible for them to hold France that in the long run, France was just too preponderant, too strong relative to England for that ever to have happened. But I do think that the fact that Alion is relieved and that Charles, his war captains and the men who have rallied to his banner, find that when they go out deep into English and Burgundian held France, actually everything falls to pieces. The whole stack of cards falls to pieces. They wouldn't have done that without Joan. I mean, it may be that Joan is, I mean, she is effectively kind of calling her
让我们回到叙述。所以基本上随着特鲁瓦的陷落，通往兰斯的道路敞开了，英国人和勃艮第人永远无法组织起来及时集结军队。这对王储来说是巨大的好消息。嗯，只是想接着说，在奥尔良解围后，帕泰战役，英国军队被削弱了。他们可以派人从英国调集更多军队，而且迟早会这样。
enemy's bluff. But, you know, it took a peasant girl ignorant of war to do that. And that is an astonishing story. And it's not surprising, I think, that for her supporters, she is an incredibly potent and glamorous figure. And for her enemies, she is a figure of dread. someone who seems to have exercised witchcraft. So I've taken you slightly off the narrative.
但目前，还没有力量来对抗向兰斯的推进。而贞德不会知道这一点。她没有理解这一点的军事敏感性。但我认为她有一种直觉，这是我们的时刻，上帝与我们同在，事实证明她是正确的。也许是因为错误的原因。对。所以让我们回到王储和叙述。所以王储，到7月16日，他在距离圣
Let's get back to the narrative. So basically with the fall of Trois, the road to chasse lies open, and the English and the Burgundians are never going to be able to organize themselves to get an army in the way in time. And this is tremendous news for the Dofan. Well, just to pick up on that, in the wake of Allior, the Battle at Pate, English forces are depleted. They could send for more forces to come from England, and in due course they will.
一个叫塞特-索的地方12英里处，一切看起来都很好。所以来自兰斯的政要们到达了，他们向他表示臣服。那天下午，7月16日，被流放出城市十多年的兰斯大主教进入了城市，那天晚上，王储和贞德紧随其后。那一定是一个多么令人惊叹的场景。对于法国游击队员来说，在经历了这么长时间后，终于看到王储和贞德到达城市，真是不可思议。是的。与此同时，一直与他们同行的吉尔·德·雷这个阴险的人物，前往了圣雷米修道院，那个在一千年前几乎为克洛维施洗的人。这是从天堂带来的油
But for now, there aren't the forces to oppose the advance on Rance. And Joan would not have known that. She doesn't have the military sensibility to understand that. But I think that she has a kind of gut feeling, this is our moment, God is with us, and she turns out to be right. Perhaps for the wrong reasons. Right. So let's get up to the Dofah and the narrative. So the Dofah, by the 16th of July, he is 12 miles out St.
由一只鸽子。它被保存在圣安瓿中，那是一个罗马玻璃瓶。这就是你必须用来涂抹国王的油。他拿到了它，回来了，所以那天准备好了。不幸的是，查理曼大帝的王权象征，比如剑、王冠等等，都在巴黎郊外的圣但尼修道院，而那里仍然处于英国占领之下，所以他们拿不到。但铁匠们被派去工作，制作了一个临时王冠，所以基本上一切准备就绪，必须这样做，加冕礼可以继续进行。所以它在第二天开始，
at a place called set-soe and all is looking good. So dignitaries from Rance arrive and they offer their submission to him. And that afternoon, the 16th of July, the Archbishop of Rens, who has been exiled from the city for more than a decade, he goes into the city and then that evening he is followed by the Dauphin, Joan, at his side. What an amazing scene that must have been. Incredible for French partisans to see the Dauphan and Joan arriving in the city at last after all this time. Yeah. And the sinister figure of Gilles-Tor-Rae, meanwhile, who's been writing with them, he has headed out to the Abbey of Saint-Rémy, the guy who had a baptised Clovis almost a thousand years before. And this was oil that had been brought down from heaven
早晨，9点，那是1429年7月17日。王储查理接近主祭坛。
by a dove. And it was kept in the holy ampula, which was a vial of Roman glass. And this is what you had to use to anoint the king. He gets it, comes back, so that's ready for the day. Unfortunately, the regalia of Charlemagne, so a sword, a crown and so on, this is in the abbey of San Deney just outside Paris, and that is still under English occupation, so they can't get that. But blacksmiths are sent to work, a makeshift crown is produced, and so basically everything is ready to go, needs must, the coronation can go ahead. And so it begins the following, morning, 9 o'clock, it's the 17th of July, 1429. Charles, the dauphin, approaches the high altar.
阿朗松公爵在等他。阿朗松公爵封查理为骑士。查理随后被呈献给上帝。他被涂上了油，从圣雷米修道院带来的圣油。然后他被兰斯大主教加冕。在整个仪式中，贞德都在王储身边，拿着她美丽的白旗。当加冕礼完成后，她跪在王储面前，告诉他，高贵的国王，上帝的旨意完成了，然后她泪流满面。
The Duke of Alonsohn is waiting for him. The Duke of Alonanon knights, Charles. Charles is then presented to God. He's touched with oil, the holy oil that has been brought from the Abbey of Saint-Rémy. And he is then crowned by the Archbishop of Rance. And throughout the ceremony, Joan is by the side of the dauphin, holding her beautiful white banner. And when the coronation has been completed, she falls to her knees before the dauphin, and she tells him noble king, God's will is done, and then she breaks down in tears.
阿隆索恩公爵正在等他。阿隆索恩公爵封查理为骑士。随后，查理被引荐给上帝。他被涂上了圣油，那是从圣雷米修道院带来的圣油。接着，他由兰斯大主教加冕。在整个仪式过程中，贞德一直站在王储身边，手持她那面美丽的白色旗帜。加冕仪式完成后，她跪在王储面前，对他说：高贵的国王，上帝的旨意已经完成，随后她泪流满面。
Oh, tear-jurking scene. And meanwhile, the new, the king, as I guess we should call him, Charles the 7th, he's granting all sorts of favours, isn't he? So fan favourite, Gilles de Réé, is made a Marshal of France. Guillaire, Foude LaValle, future Aristot, who we heard from at the beginning, he's a count. The bastard of Orleans is there. That bloke, the wrath of God is there. Renéé-en-en-en-ju is there, all these characters. And actually, Jones family are there too. So this is a signal honor for them. I mean, they basically, I mean, they were respectable peasants, but they were peasants nonetheless. And now here they are at the coronation of the king. And being put up at public expense. So it's, yeah, it's incredible. Her father, her brothers,
哦，真是个催人泪下的场景。与此同时，这位新国王，我想我们应该这样称呼他，查理七世，他正在授予各种恩惠，不是吗？所以，粉丝最爱吉尔·德·雷被封为法国元帅。我们一开始听到的未来的亚里士多德，吉约姆·富德·拉瓦尔，他成了伯爵。奥尔良的私生子也在那里。那个家伙，上帝之怒也在那里。勒内·安茹也在那里，所有这些人物都在。事实上，琼的家人也在那里。所以这对他们来说是一种极大的荣誉。我的意思是，他们基本上，我的意思是，他们是受人尊敬的农民，但他们毕竟还是农民。现在他们竟然出现在国王的加冕典礼上。而且还是由公共开支供养。所以，是的，这真是不可思议。她的父亲，她的兄弟们，
her godfather. And Charles is the king, as we're called. him from now on. I mean, he is very keen to show them marks a favor. So at the end of July, he announces that Jones Village, Domremi, will be exempt in perpetuity from taxes. Wow. And then a few months after that in December, incredibly, he announces the ennoblement of Joan, her family, all the descendants of her family. And again, this is something that, in perpetuity, it will last right the way up to the French Revolution. They return their nobility. And, you know, you would have to say, I think maybe even you, Dominic, that these honours are very worthily given, that the coronation of Charles the 7th simply wouldn't have happened without Joan.
她的教父。查理现在是国王了，我们从现在开始这样称呼他。我的意思是，他非常热衷于向他们展示恩宠。所以七月底，他宣布琼的家乡栋雷米将永久免税。哇。几个月后的十二月，令人难以置信的是，他宣布授予琼、她的家人以及她家族的所有后代贵族身份。同样，这也是一件永久的事情，它将一直持续到法国大革命。他们恢复了贵族身份。而且，你知道，你不得不说，我想也许连你，多米尼克，也会认为这些荣誉是当之无愧的，如果没有琼，查理七世的加冕典礼根本就不会发生。
And that it proves, as Joan had always said it would, it proves to be an event of colossal significance in the history of the 100 years war. because Charles's legitimacy has now essentially been proclaimed to the world. The stain of that crime at the Bridge of Montreux, the murder of the Duke of Burgundy. It's effectively been washed clean. And so now all of Christendom is holding its breath to see how the English, how the Burgundians, servants of a rival king of France, Henry of Lancaster, how are they going to respond? Collie, we'll find out after the break. I am mighty prince, Duke of Burgundy.
这证明了，正如琼一直所说的那样，这被证明是百年战争史上具有重大意义的事件。因为查理的合法性现在基本上已经向全世界宣告了。蒙特罗桥上那场罪行的污点，即谋杀勃艮第公爵的罪行，实际上已经被洗清了。所以现在整个基督教世界都在屏息以待，看看英国人，看看作为法国竞争对手亨利·兰开斯特的仆人的勃艮第人，他们将如何回应？科利，休息之后我们就会知道。我是伟大的王子，勃艮第公爵。
Joan the maid calls upon you by the King of Heaven, my rightful and sovereign lord, that you as a King of France should make a good and lasting peace. Forgive one another entirely, in good faith, as loyal Christians should do. And if you wish to make war, then do so against the Saracens. Oh, Joan of Art there totally lets herself down
圣女贞德以我的合法和主权领主，天堂之王的名义呼吁你，作为法国国王，你应该实现持久的和平。像忠诚的基督徒应该做的那样，真诚地完全宽恕彼此。如果你想发动战争，那就去对抗撒拉逊人吧。哦，圣女贞德在那里完全让自己失望了
and throws away all the goodwill that she's built up in two and a half episodes by this absolute, she wants to attack the Middle East. That's poor. Theo would not approve of that. Well, but also, she also wants to attack the Hussites, so she wants to have a crack at the checks. Oh, come on. This is absolutely shocking.
并抛弃了她在两集半里建立起来的所有善意，因为这个绝对的，她想攻击中东。这太糟糕了。西奥不会赞同这一点。嗯，但同时，她也想攻击胡斯派，所以她想挑战捷克人。哦，拜托。这绝对令人震惊。
Yeah, but, but, Dominic, of course, what she's doing there is trying to patch things up between Charles I seventh and the greatest peer in France, the Duke of Burgundy. And she writes that letter on the very day of Charles of 7th's coronation in Rance. And this is because she finds it puzzling and frustrating that Philip the Good, the Duke of Burgundy, the most senior of all the peers in France, hadn't opted to come to the ceremony. Because he's a French nobleman of the Blood Royal. Why is he not there? Why is he not rallying to the French cause?
是的，但是，但是，多米尼克，当然，她这样做是试图修补查理七世与法国最伟大的贵族勃艮第公爵之间的关系。她在查理七世在兰斯加冕的那一天写了那封信。这是因为她感到困惑和沮丧，为什么法国所有贵族中地位最高的勃艮第公爵菲利普好人没有选择参加仪式。因为他是拥有皇室血统的法国贵族。他为什么不在那里？他为什么不团结在法国事业周围？
Why is he busy fighting other Frenchmen? Hold on. Does she genuinely not know? I mean, surely she must know that there's the Armagnac Burgundian Civil War. I do not think that she is entirely inhabiting the dimension of conventional geopolitics. I think she feels that God's hand is evident in everything that's happened and that therefore the Duke of Burgundy should accept that and should knuckle down and should repent of all his previous errors. I think that's her feeling. The Duke of Burgundy is a smart guy, right?
他为什么忙着与其他法国人作战？等等。她真的不知道吗？我的意思是，她肯定知道阿马尼亚克与勃艮第内战的存在。我不认为她完全处于传统地缘政治的维度中。我认为她觉得上帝之手在发生的一切事情中都是显而易见的，因此勃艮第公爵应该接受这一点，应该屈服，应该忏悔他之前所有的错误。我想这就是她的感受。勃艮第公爵是个聪明人，对吧？
Philip the Good. And I mean, now that he sees that the tide has turning in the war, he's a mercurial man. Yeah, he would be an absolute dope if he didn't start thinking, maybe the English aren't going to win this after all, and I could think about changing sides. Well, I think he'd certainly been thinking that before Charles launched his march towards a rance.
菲利普好人。我的意思是，既然他看到战争的局势正在转变，他是一个反复无常的人。是的，如果他不开始想，也许英国人毕竟不会赢，我可以考虑倒戈，那他就是一个彻头彻尾的笨蛋。嗯，我想在查理发动向兰斯的进军之前，他肯定已经在考虑这个问题了。
And in fact, that was one of the reasons why many of his advisors said, look, don't go for it. Because we've got a real chance here of patching things up with the Duke of Burgundy. And if we invade all his territories and, you know, seize towns that are kind of loyal to him, then we'll really crash that opportunity. And actually, that is what happens because Philip is very alarmed by the fact that Charles 7th is now in Rance and has taken Troyes and all this kind of thing. And so one week before Charles's coronation in France, Philip had traveled to Paris where the Duke of Bedford, the regent for Henry of Lancaster, was installed. And there they renew the peace treaty between England and Burgundy. Now, it is true, as you said, Philip's a very smart and shrewd operator. So even as he is signing that, renewing that treaty with the English, he is also sending it an envoy to Charles who arrives in the wake of the coronation, kind of. saying, well, you know, should we at least have negotiations? And they do. But ultimately, Philip just cannot bring himself to let bygones be bygones. You know, he sees Charles the seventh as the guy who had sponsored the murder of his father. Yeah, it's not wrong.
事实上，这也是他的许多顾问说，看，不要去的原因之一。因为我们在这里有一个真正修补与勃艮第公爵关系的机会。如果我们入侵他所有的领土，你知道，夺取那些对他忠诚的城镇，那么我们就会真正摧毁那个机会。事实上，事情就是这样发生的，因为菲利普对查理七世现在在兰斯并占领了特鲁瓦等城市感到非常震惊。所以就在查理在兰斯加冕前一周，菲利普前往巴黎，亨利·兰开斯特的摄政王贝德福德公爵就在那里。在那里，他们续签了英格兰和勃艮第之间的和平条约。现在，正如你所说，菲利普是一个非常聪明和精明的经营者，这是真的。所以即使他在签署、续签与英国人的条约时，他也同时派遣了一名特使前往查理那里，他在加冕典礼后到达，某种程度上说，好吧，你知道，我们至少应该进行谈判吗？他们确实进行了。但最终，菲利普就是无法让自己既往不咎。你知道，他把查理七世视为赞助谋杀他父亲的人。是的，这没错。
Yeah. And he just can't bring himself to do it. And so, despite the coronation of Charles of Seventh at Raz, the Anglo-Bugundian pact hold, Phillips' alliance, with. Bedford remains secure. Okay. So let's go to the Duke of Bedford. So the Duke of Bedford, we've described him. He's the main English commander in France. He's basically the person that Henry V has given power.
是的。他就是无法让自己那样做。所以，尽管查理七世在兰斯加冕，英勃同盟依然稳固，菲利普与贝德福德的联盟依然稳固。好的。那么让我们谈谈贝德福德公爵。所以贝德福德公爵，我们已经描述过他了。他是英国在法国的主要指挥官。他基本上是亨利五世赋予权力的人。
After Henry the fifth's death, he is the person who holds the reins of power. And he's a very serious person. And he's looking at this situation. Basically, in the course of, what, three months? Yeah. His position in France has begun very swiftly to erode. He thought he was going to breach the Loire and prosecute the war into south central France. Now he's lost Orleans.
在亨利五世去世后，他是掌握权力缰绳的人。他是一个非常严肃的人。他正在审视这种情况。基本上，在三个月的时间里？是的。他在法国的地位开始迅速削弱。他以为他会突破卢瓦尔河，将战争推进到法国中南部。现在他失去了奥尔良。
Two of his key captains Suffolk and Talbot have been taken prisoner. Champagne has been lost. So that's their sort of eastern flank of Paris. And this business in France is a disaster for the English cause because the Dauphin has been crowned. And the English claimant to the throne of France, Henry of Lancaster, Henry the 6th, is still only a very little boy and a very dreamy and pious little boy at that, not martial at all. So what does the Duke of Bedford do now? I guess first of all, he has to try and work out what on earth has gone wrong. Yeah, well, he needs to find someone to blame.
他的两名关键队长萨福克和塔尔博特被俘虏了。香槟地区已经丢失。所以那是他们巴黎东翼的防线。在法国的这件事对英国的事业来说是一场灾难，因为王太子已经加冕了。而英国的法国王位觊觎者，亨利·兰开斯特，亨利六世，仍然只是一个非常小的男孩，而且是一个非常爱做梦和虔诚的小男孩，一点也不尚武。那么贝德福德公爵现在该怎么办？我想首先，他必须试着弄清楚到底出了什么问题。是的，好吧，他需要找个人来责怪。
And Bedford himself has no doubt who to blame, and that is Joan, because he feels that she is a witch and that she has deployed sorcery to undermine his administration. And he sees her as a harlot, as a whore. People who listened to our previous episode may remember that whore was the word that was constantly being used by the English when they addressed Joan.
贝德福德本人毫无疑问该责怪谁，那就是琼，因为他觉得她是一个女巫，她利用巫术来破坏他的政府。他视她为荡妇，为妓女。听过我们上一集的人可能还记得，妓女是英国人在称呼琼时不断使用的词。
This is a girl who dresses herself as a man and has run away with men at arms. you know, is in the middle of a huge army. So clearly she is a whore in their opinion. And yet she has the nerve to call herself the Pussell, the virgin, the maid. So clearly she's a witch. And that being so, it is vital that she is captured and that her witchcraft is demonstrated to the satisfaction of Christendom as a whole.
这是一个把自己打扮成男人并与武装人员一起逃跑的女孩。你知道，身处一支庞大的军队之中。所以很明显，在他们看来她是一个妓女。然而，她竟然有胆量称自己为“处女”，即圣女。所以很明显她是一个女巫。既然如此，至关重要的是她必须被俘虏，并且她的巫术必须被证明，以满足整个基督教世界。
Because if that happens, then the right of Henry of Lancaster to the French throne will be spectacularly reinvigorated. And just as germanely, the claim of Charles the seventh to the throne will be hopefully knee-capped fatally, because you can't rule if you depend on your coronation on a witch. Yeah, of course. So this is the plan. And Bedford is not alone in his conviction.
因为如果发生了这种情况，那么亨利·兰开斯特对法国王位的权利将得到惊人的重振。同样重要的是，查理七世对王位的要求希望会被致命地削弱，因为如果你在加冕典礼上依赖一个女巫，你就无法统治。是的，当然。这就是计划。贝德福德并不是唯一有这种信念的人。
Basically everyone in the English regime and in the court of Burgundy pretty much hold to this opinion. And they don't do it cynically. They genuinely think she's a witch, right? Yeah, I think they genuinely think it. This isn't just policy, yeah. Yeah, and what they're doing there is that they, like Charles VIII and the people who admire Joan,
基本上，英国政权和勃艮第宫廷里的每个人几乎都持有这种观点。而且他们这样做并不是愤世嫉俗。他们真的认为她是一个女巫，对吧？是的，我认为他们真的这么认为。这不仅仅是政策，是的。是的，他们这样做是因为他们，像查理七世和那些钦佩琼的人一样，
are paying acknowledgement to the sheer weirdness and improbability of everything that she's done. So to quote Marina Warner, the English side believed in Joan the maid more than the French. and they had to because if it's not the fault of Joan, then there are systemic problems with their regime that they don't really want to face up to. Yeah. Well, the problems that we talked about earlier on, the overextension and the fact that basically victory is probably beyond them, whatever they do. And no one wants to admit that.
正在承认她所做的一切的纯粹怪异和不可思议。引用玛丽娜·华纳的话，英国方面比法国人更相信圣女贞德。他们必须相信，因为如果不是琼的错，那么他们的政权就存在他们并不真正想面对的系统性问题。是的。嗯，我们之前谈到的问题，过度扩张以及事实上胜利可能对他们来说遥不可及，无论他们做什么。没有人想承认这一点。
So it becomes easier to blame it all on witchcraft, right? Right. But also, I mean, it is a tribute to the renown of Joan that this is taken very seriously, that if they can capture her, then, you know, that everything will be put back on a straight course. Now, the good news for Bedford and for a patriotic listeners to this podcast is that it's at precisely this point in the wake of Charles's coronation that Jones Star, which has been very high and as high as it could possibly be, you get the first signs that is just beginning to dim, don't you? Yeah. Up to this point, everything that she has said she will do, she has done. but by early September, so that's a month or so after the coronation in Raz, she and the Duke of Alessor, who, you know, her biggest fan among the ranks of the French captains,
所以把这一切归咎于巫术变得更容易了，对吧？对。但同时，我的意思是，琼的声誉很高，这被非常认真地对待，如果他们能俘虏她，那么，你知道，一切都会回到正轨。现在，对贝德福德和这个播客的爱国听众来说，好消息是，正是在查理加冕后的这一点上，琼的明星，一直非常高，高到不能再高了，你看到了它刚刚开始暗淡的最初迹象，不是吗？是的。到目前为止，她说她会做的每一件事，她都做了。但到了九月初，也就是兰斯加冕典礼一个月左右，她和阿朗松公爵，你知道，她在法国队长中最大的粉丝，
they arrive before the gates of Paris. And in the opinion of Joan, Paris is ripe for the plucking. And she says, you know, I have been assured by my voices that if we attack it in a full-throated way, the city will fall. And the reason for this is that it's pretty isolated. Champagne has effectively, at least the major cities in Champagne, have been conquered by Charles the 7th. So among them is a city called Beauvais, dominated by a towering cathedral, but only half
他们到达了巴黎城门前。在琼看来，巴黎已经成熟，可以采摘了。她说，你知道，我的声音向我保证，如果我们以全力攻击它，这座城市就会陷落。原因是它相当孤立。香槟地区实际上，至少香槟的主要城市，已经被查理七世征服了。所以其中有一个城市叫博韦，由一座高耸的大教堂主宰，但只有一半
finished. And for one man in the circle of the Duke of Bedford, this is a particular humiliation. And this man is a guy we've already met. We met him in the first episode. He is called Pierre Couchon, and he's the bishop of Beauvais. And he's the guy who thought the English are going to win and he'd thrown his lot in with the English and he thought, you know, they're going to win and that's God's will. Yeah. And now he has lost the city that is probably his sea to the French and more specifically to this fiend in female form, this sorceress, this witch.
完工。对于贝德福德公爵圈子里的一个人来说，这是一种特别的羞辱。这个人就是我们已经见过的人。我们在第一集里见过他。他叫皮埃尔·科雄，他是博韦的主教。他就是那个认为英国人会赢，并把自己的命运与英国人联系在一起，他认为，你知道，他们会赢，那是上帝的旨意。是的。现在他失去了可能是他主教座的城市，输给了法国人，更具体地说是输给了这个女性形态的恶魔，这个女巫，这个女巫。
And so he like Bedford has particular cause now to view Joan in a very, very dark light. And he, no less than Bedford, is desperate for her to be captured and hopefully to have her wickedness exposed. And actually, events start to play into his hands, don't they? They do. Because, what is it, the 8th of September, Joan launches this great attack on Paris. Now, some listeners may be thinking, you know, the relief of Orleans is very famous. How come the liberation of Paris isn't so famous? Well, there's an answer, isn't there?
所以他像贝德福德一样，现在有特别的理由以非常非常黑暗的眼光看待琼。他，不亚于贝德福德，渴望她被俘虏，并希望她的邪恶被揭露。事实上，事件开始向有利于他的方向发展，不是吗？确实。因为，是什么时候，9月8日，琼对巴黎发动了这次大进攻。现在，一些听众可能在想，你知道，奥尔良的解围非常有名。为什么巴黎的解放不那么有名？嗯，有一个答案，不是吗？
Because this does not go according to plan for Joan. It does not. I mean, she attacks with a very, very small number of men. Charles of Seventh is very skeptical that she can take Paris and has refused basically to join her. And so it all goes wrong. The end of the assault, 500 of her men are left dead or dying before the walls of the city. The man carrying her standard is hit in the eye by a crossbow bolt. So it's very Harold at the Battle of Hastings. And Joan herself has to be stretched from the walls after she gets hit in the thigh. this is obviously a massive embarrassment. She'd said she would capture Paris and now she hasn't. Joan implies this is basically because Charles O'7 didn't trust me. If everyone had piled in, we would have got it. And she may well have been right about that, actually. Paris kind of was quite vulnerable, maybe a full force, but a gamble because Paris is the
因为这对琼来说并没有按计划进行。确实没有。我的意思是，她用极少数人进行了攻击。查理七世非常怀疑她能否拿下巴黎，基本上拒绝加入她。所以一切都搞砸了。袭击结束时，她的500名士兵死在城墙前。扛着她旗帜的人眼睛被弩箭射中。所以这非常像黑斯廷斯战役中的哈罗德。琼本人在大腿中箭后不得不被从城墙上拉下来。这显然是一个巨大的尴尬。她说她会占领巴黎，现在她没有。琼暗示这基本上是因为查理七世不信任我。如果每个人都全力以赴，我们就会成功。事实上，关于这一点她很可能是对的。巴黎确实相当脆弱，也许是全力以赴，但这是一场赌博，因为巴黎是
best defended city basically west of Constantinople. I mean, its fortifications are enormous. But also, there is this whole issue of the Civil War. which has always been bubbling away, the mass of people in Paris are very pro-Bugundian, and Charles VIII is, you know, I mean, he's on the Amniac side. Yeah.
基本上君士坦丁堡以西防御最好的城市。我的意思是，它的防御工事非常巨大。但同时，还有整个内战的问题。这总是沸沸扬扬，巴黎的大多数人非常亲勃艮第，而查理七世是，你知道，我的意思是，他站在阿马尼亚克一边。是的。
And so all these circumstances combined to explain it, but there's also one additional factor, which is used to explain Joan's failure to capture Paris. This is actually quite damaging to her. And this is that the 8th of September is the birthday of the Virgin Mary, and it is therefore seen as very disrespectful of Joan to have launched in the time.
所以所有这些情况结合起来解释了这一点，但还有一个额外的因素，被用来解释琼未能占领巴黎。这实际上对她相当有害。这就是9月8日是圣母玛利亚的生日，因此琼在这一天发动攻击被认为是非常不尊重的。
attack on that day. So that casts a slight aspersion on the notion of her holiness. Well, I suppose you could argue, I mean, again, if you're being just sort of strictly empirical about it, she's gambled and gambled and gambled and one day, you know, it won't work. You compared her with, in the previous episode, you mentioned her basball quality, which for people who don't know, it's the England cricket coach who just believes in constant aggression and attacking, even in the face of overwhelming odds.
所以这给她的神圣性蒙上了一层阴影。嗯，我想你可以争辩说，我的意思是，同样，如果你只是严格地从经验主义的角度来看，她赌了又赌，赌了又赌，有一天，你知道，它就不会奏效了。你在上一集中把她比作，你提到了她的“巴兹球”品质，对于不知道的人来说，这是英格兰板球教练，他只相信持续的进攻和攻击，即使面对压倒性的困难。
And, you know, sometimes that works and it's brilliant. And then sometimes you're Tom Holland and you go to watch a test match and it only takes two days because England of shame themselves. And that's basically the siege of Paris. Yeah. And I think in the wake of this, even though her fame across Europe remains absolutely constant, people think she's, you know, this incredible wonder. People can't stop talking about her. She's this massive celebrity. I think at the Charles's court, there is a sense that perhaps something has changed.
而且，你知道，有时这很有效，而且很精彩。然后有时你是汤姆·霍兰德，你去观看一场测试赛，它只用了两天，因为英格兰让自己蒙羞了。这基本上就是巴黎围城战。是的。我认为在此之后，尽管她在欧洲的声誉依然绝对稳定，人们认为她是，你知道，这个不可思议的奇迹。人们谈论她停不下来。她是这个巨大的名人。我认为在查理的宫廷里，有一种感觉，也许有些事情已经改变了。
And this is basically because she's done what she said she'd do. She said that she would relieve all year. She's done it. She said that she would take Charles to rounds and crown him. And that she's done as well. Basically, what is there left for her to do? They don't need her. They don't need her anymore.
这基本上是因为她做了她说她会做的事。她说她会解围奥尔良。她做到了。她说她会带查理去兰斯并为他加冕。她也做到了。基本上，她还有什么可做的？他们不需要她了。他们不再需要她了。
They don't need her. But also, I mean, by her own standards, those were the two things she set herself to do. She's done it. So what now? And it's obvious, I think also to everyone at the court that Joan really, really enjoys being, you know, a captain. She doesn't want to go back to her village. She doesn't want to take off her beautiful armour and her, you know, her rich furs and
他们不需要她了。但我的意思是，按照她自己的标准，那是她为自己设定的两件事。她做到了。那么现在呢？我认为宫廷里的每个人也都显而易见，琼真的，真的喜欢成为，你知道，一名队长。她不想回到她的村庄。她不想脱下她美丽的盔甲和她，你知道，她昂贵的皮草和
everything and go back to her kind of peasant girls' dress. You know, that's not what she's about at all. And so all that winter, rather than return to Don Ramey, Joan is saying to the king, come on, let's keep going. Let's attack the English in Normandy. It'll be brilliant. We'll sweep them into the sea, despite the fact that. Charles is not going to do this because the English are very strong in Normandy and he, again,
一切，回到她那种村姑的装束。你知道，那根本不是她想要的。所以整个冬天，琼没有回到栋雷米，而是对国王说，来吧，让我们继续。让我们攻击诺曼底的英国人。那会很棒。我们会把他们扫进大海，尽管事实上。查理不会这样做，因为英国人在诺曼底非常强大，而且他，再次，
this Brenno problem, he doesn't have the money for it. You know, and money issues are not the, you know, that's not Jones Fybe at all. Right. She's not worried about that. Yeah. So basically, um, her vision and reality are coming into increasingly, you know, they're colliding with increasingly kind of destabilizing effect for her reputation at the court, right? Right. I mean, I think that, you know, we've, we have this incredible description of how her as someone from the court of King Arthur. She is operating in the dimension of romance. Charles is operating in the dimension of reality spreadsheets and budgets and, you know, and the two don't really gel. So by March 1430, Joan has had enough. And she thinks, well, if if no one else
这个布雷诺问题，他没有钱。你知道，金钱问题根本不是，你知道，那根本不是琼的强项。对。她不担心那个。是的。所以基本上，嗯，她的愿景和现实正在变得越来越，你知道，它们正在发生碰撞，对她在宫廷的声誉产生了越来越不稳定的影响，对吧？对。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，我们有这个关于她作为来自亚瑟王宫廷的人的不可思议的描述。她在浪漫的维度中运作。查理在现实、电子表格和预算的维度中运作，你知道，两者并没有真正融合。所以到1430年3月，琼受够了。她想，好吧，如果其他人
is going to continue the war, then I'm going to do this myself. And so she raises a company of men, 200 men in all, and among them is her brother Pierre, who had joined her at Rance. And basically, she turns freelance. And Dominic, we've talked about these companies before, these free companies. They're bands of soldiers who, you know, might very easily seem to those who are attacked by them as bandits. And they had been a plague in France throughout the length of the Hundred Years' War. And it seems to some that Joan, you know, this holy maid, has now joined the ranks of the free companies.
不打算继续战争，那么我就自己做。所以她召集了一支队伍，总共200人，其中有她的兄弟皮埃尔，他在兰斯加入了她。基本上，她成了自由职业者。多米尼克，我们之前谈过这些公司，这些自由公司。他们是士兵团伙，你知道，在那些被他们攻击的人看来，他们很容易被视为强盗。在整个百年战争期间，他们一直是法国的瘟疫。在某些人看来，琼，你知道，这个圣女，现在已经加入了自由公司的行列。
And this is a very, very bad look for her. Joan herself would absolutely have repudiated that charge. I mean, she would have said, well, I'm doing what Charles and his captains should have been doing. I'm taking the fight to the English. I'm taking the fight to the Burgundians. And to be fair to her, all that April, she and her company are roaming from flashpoint to flashpoint, supporting the French in their battles and their sieges against the Burgundians, roaming the badlands that now surround Paris, trying to prosecute the war. And in this spirit,
这对她来说是一个非常非常糟糕的形象。琼本人绝对会否认这一指控。我的意思是，她会说，好吧，我正在做查理和他的队长们应该做的事情。我正在把战斗带给英国人。我正在把战斗带给勃艮第人。公平地说，整个四月，她和她的公司都在从一个冲突点游荡到另一个冲突点，支持法国人在他们对抗勃艮第人的战斗和围城中，在现在环绕巴黎的荒地上游荡，试图进行战争。在这种精神下，
on the 23rd of May 1430, she arrives at a town called Compienne, and this is some 50 miles north of Paris, and it is under siege by the Duke of Burgundy, because Compienne had owed loyalty to the Duke of Burgundy and had then switched its alliance to Charles the 7th. And so now the Duke of Burgundy is out for revenge. And Joan says, OK, I'm going to get right there, and I'm going to try and relieve compienne. Aulian style. Oliant style. And this, now, not only that the Jones say she's going to do this, but she is acting on
1430年5月23日，她到达了一个叫贡比涅的城镇，这在巴黎以北约50英里处，它正受到勃艮第公爵的围攻，因为贡比涅曾效忠于勃艮第公爵，后来又将联盟转向了查理七世。所以现在勃艮第公爵要报复。琼说，好吧，我要去那里，我要试着解围贡比涅。奥尔良风格。奥尔良风格。现在，不仅琼说她要这样做，而且她是在
the advice of her voices, because her voices are still there. We haven't mentioned her voices for a while, but the voices are still giving her divine instructions, aren't they? And they say, charge across the drawbridge, attack the Burgundian siege positions. And you know what? You are going to capture the Duke of Burgundy himself. and at sunset she launches this sortie, this 23rd of May 1430. And talk us through how this attack goes, Tom.
她的声音的建议下行事的，因为她的声音还在那里。我们有一段时间没提到她的声音了，但声音仍然在给她神圣的指示，不是吗？他们说，冲过吊桥，攻击勃艮第的围攻阵地。你知道吗？你将俘虏勃艮第公爵本人。在日落时分，她发动了这次突击，1430年5月23日。汤姆，给我们讲讲这次攻击是怎么进行的。
Well, it doesn't go well. It gets beaten back by the Burgundians and trumpet has sound the retreat. But Joan, of course, she's not a girl for a retreat. So rather than obey the summons, she stays on the edge of the battle. Of course, she's not fighting. Joan doesn't herself fight. but she is a splendid figure. She's splendid in her white armour.
嗯，进行得不顺利。它被勃艮第人击退了，号角吹响了撤退。但琼，当然，她不是一个会撤退的女孩。所以她没有服从召唤，而是留在了战斗的边缘。当然，她没有战斗。琼自己不战斗。但她是一个辉煌的人物。她穿着白色的盔甲，光彩照人。
She's got her silk and banner aloft. Everyone in that battle, Burgundian as well as French, absolutely knows who she is. So eventually she heads back towards the drawbridge, towards the gate, but by now the guards in Compienne are worried that the Burgundians will break in if they leave it open. So very reluctantly, they close the gates
她高举着丝绸旗帜。那场战斗中的每个人，勃艮第人以及法国人，绝对都知道她是谁。所以最终她朝吊桥方向，朝大门方向撤退，但此时贡比涅的守卫担心如果他们敞开大门，勃艮第人会闯进来。所以非常不情愿地，他们关上了大门
and they pull up the drawbridge, and Joan is now stuck on the wrong side. of the moat. And so she's surrounded by a swarm of Burgundian soldiers. She's pulled down from her horse. She rises to her feet. She draws her sword. She looks around for a suitable person to surrender to. There's a Burgundian captain and she hands a sword over to him. And Jean-La Pusel is now a prisoner. So Philip the Good, the Duke of Burgundy. Oh, he must be absolutely delighted. Yeah. So we have a witness who sees him. He, he, he, He comes to inspect Joan and the witness says, I've never seen anyone so delighted.
他们拉起了吊桥，琼现在被困在了护城河的错误一侧。所以她被一群勃艮第士兵包围了。她被从马上拉了下来。她站起身来。她拔出剑。她环顾四周寻找一个合适的人投降。有一个勃艮第队长，她把剑交给了他。圣女贞德现在成了俘虏。所以菲利普好人，勃艮第公爵。哦，他一定非常高兴。是的。所以我们有一位目击者看到了他。他，他，他，他来视察琼，目击者说，我从未见过任何人如此高兴。
And that evening after the Duke of Burgundy has been to look at Joan, he writes letters to all the towns in France and the low countries who might have been tempted to rebel against him. And he proclaims, you know, this glorious achievement. Jones capture, we are certain, will everywhere be greeted as the most splendid news, for it clearly demonstrates the error and foolish credulity of all those who have let themselves be convinced by the deeds of this woman. And as it turns out, Jones Capter is a servant of a particularly proficient Burgundian Lord, a very loyal servant, not just of the Duke of Burgundy himself, but of Bedford and
那天晚上，勃艮第公爵看过琼之后，他写信给法国和低地国家所有可能试图反抗他的城镇。他宣称，你知道，这一辉煌的成就。琼的被俘，我们确信，到处都会被视为最辉煌的消息，因为它清楚地证明了所有那些让自己被这个女人的事迹所说服的人的错误和愚蠢的轻信。事实证明，琼的俘虏是一位特别精干的勃艮第领主，一位非常忠诚的仆人，不仅是对勃艮第公爵本人，而且是对贝德福德和
the English cause. He's called John of Luxembourg. He has a, you know, he's a very serious player, a very loyal servant of the Anglo-Bergan. a Gundian alliance. And so this is the person into whose hands Joan now passes. And Joan, of course, you know, she sees herself as a knight. She is now of noble standing. She sees herself, therefore, as a prisoner of war whose treatment should be governed by the laws of war. And John of Luxembourg is not reluctant to buy into this. Because of course, if Joan is a prisoner of war is of noble standing, then he stands to make a lot of money. Huge profit. He can, you know, ransom her,
英国的事业。他叫卢森堡的约翰。他有一个，你知道，他是一个非常严肃的参与者，是英勃同盟的非常忠诚的仆人。所以这就是琼现在落入其手中的人。当然，琼，你知道，她把自己视为一名骑士。她现在具有贵族地位。因此，她把自己视为一名战俘，其待遇应受战争法管辖。卢森堡的约翰并不排斥这一点。因为当然，如果琼作为战俘具有贵族地位，那么他就能赚很多钱。巨额利润。他可以，你知道，勒索她，
or sell her on for a large sum. But there are complications with this. Right, because who's going to pay this ransom, right? Well, you would think the obvious person is the man whose cause she has promoted for so long, who is Charles the 7th of France. But disappointingly, Charles the 7th, he, I reckon, you see, I reckon there's a part of him that thinks, oh, thank God I've got rid of that. You know, she was becoming a bit of an albatross.
或者以高价把她卖掉。但这其中有复杂之处。对，因为谁会支付这笔赎金，对吧？嗯，你会认为显而易见的人是她长期以来一直推动其事业的人，即法国的查理七世。但令人失望的是，查理七世，他，我想，你看，我想他的一部分人认为，哦，谢天谢地，我摆脱了那个。你知道，她正变得有点像个累赘。
A bit of a nightmare. Yeah, a bit of a nightmare. I'm kind of glad that they've got her now and I don't want her back. Yes. And I think also the fact that Joan has been captured is also potentially very, very damaging. And so Charles doesn't comment on it. He never mentions Joan by word from this point on. And instead he hands over responsibility for the crisis to his chancellor, who is the Archbishop of Ravs who had crowned him.
有点像个噩梦。是的，有点像个噩梦。我很高兴他们现在抓住了她，我不想让她回来。是的。而且我认为琼被俘虏的事实也可能非常非常具有破坏性。所以查理没有对此发表评论。从这一点开始，他再也没有提过琼的名字。相反，他把危机的责任交给了他的大臣，也就是为他加冕的兰斯大主教。
and the Archbishop of Rance, who was also the guy who had led the investigation into Joan back in Poitiers before the Siege of O'Neillian, he now basically operates as Charles's spin doctor. And his take on Joan is that she'd gone rogue and that although her mission had indeed been blessed by God, she'd gone so off-peased that she has now been undone by her own pride and folly. And God has therefore punished her by allowing her to be captured. and therefore, you know, that's it. God's washed his hands of her, basically. I mean, you don't have to be incredibly cynical to believe that, though, do you?
而兰斯大主教，也是在奥尔良围城战之前在普瓦捷领导对琼调查的人，他现在基本上充当了查理的公关专家。他对琼的看法是，她已经变得不可控，虽然她的使命确实得到了上帝的祝福，但她已经走得太远了，以至于她现在被自己的骄傲和愚蠢所毁灭。因此，上帝惩罚了她，允许她被俘虏。因此，你知道，就是这样。上帝基本上已经不再管她了。我的意思是，你不必非常愤世嫉俗才能相信这一点，对吧？
Because if you believe that her previous success was blessed by God, when things go wrong, that shows that she's misunderstood God's wishes and that God has abandoned her, surely. So you could think that quite sincerely. I think you absolutely could. But it is obviously an embarrassment that this person who had sponsored the coronation, of Charles of 7th has now demonstrably failed to maintain the favour of God.
因为如果你相信她之前的成功是上帝的祝福，当事情出错时，这表明她误解了上帝的意愿，上帝抛弃了她，当然。所以你可以非常真诚地那样想。我想你绝对可以。但这一事实显然是一个尴尬，即赞助查理七世加冕典礼的这个人现在显然未能保持上帝的恩宠。
So I think in Charles' opinion, let's just keep quiet about it, let's just pretend it never happened, let's just hope the whole business will go away. Now, it's not going to go away because, of course, the goal of the Duke of Bedford is the precise opposite.
所以我认为在查理看来，让我们对此保持沉默，让我们假装它从未发生过，让我们希望整个事情会消失。现在，它不会消失，因为当然，贝德福德公爵的目标恰恰相反。
He wants to make as big a fuss of Jones' capture as he possibly can. And I think that he feels that Jones capture has given him the opportunity to pluck from the very jaws of defeat, an absolutely seismic propaganda victory. What he needs to do is basically so tarnish the coronation of Charles the 7th
他想尽可能地大肆宣扬琼的被俘。我认为他觉得琼的被俘给了他一个机会，从失败的边缘夺取一场绝对震撼的宣传胜利。他需要做的是基本上玷污查理七世的加冕典礼
that people go back to saying he's an illegitimate king. And so Bedford by now is adopting a two-pronged strategy to bring this about. firstly, the month before James capture, he had sent for the eight-year-old Henry the 6th to come to Calais. And Bedford's plan is to have him crowned in Rance or at a pinch Paris and thereby erase the memory of Charles's coronation. This is his plan. There is a problem.
以至于人们又开始说他是一个非法的国王。所以贝德福德现在正在采取双管齐下的策略来实现这一点。首先，在琼被俘的前一个月，他派人去加莱接八岁的亨利六世。贝德福德的计划是让他加冕，在兰斯或者退而求其次在巴黎，从而抹去查理加冕的记忆。这是他的计划。有一个问题。
Rance is still in enemy hands and Normandy is too unstable to risk the king traveling to Paris. So it's a bit like, you know, in the wake of the Iraq war, President Bush, you know, he could maybe land in Baghdad and stay in the green zone, but he couldn't venture out to Fallujah. There's the same issue with, you know, they can't guarantee Henry the Sixth safety. And so instead, he's left to kick his heels in Calais, and it's all a bit embarrassing. And then suddenly Joan is captured. And now Bedford can see a second massive opportunity. The witch is in the hands of one of his allies. And it is Pierre Couchon, the bishop of Beauvais,
兰斯仍然在敌人手中，诺曼底太不稳定，无法冒险让国王前往巴黎。所以这有点像，你知道，在伊拉克战争之后，布什总统，你知道，他也许能降落在巴格达并留在绿区，但他无法冒险去费卢杰。同样的问题，你知道，他们无法保证亨利六世的安全。所以相反，他只能在加莱无所事事，这有点尴尬。然后突然琼被俘虏了。现在贝德福德看到了第二个巨大的机会。女巫落入了他的一位盟友手中。而皮埃尔·科雄，博韦的主教，
within whose bishopric, crucially Joan had been captured, who now steps up to the plate with a solution that he presents to Bedford. And he says to Bedford, look, you should buy Joan off John of Luxembourg. And then when Joan is in the hands of the English, hand her over to us,
关键在于琼是在他的主教区内被俘的，他现在带着一个他向贝德福德提出的解决方案挺身而出。他对贝德福德说，看，你应该从卢森堡的约翰那里买下琼。然后当琼落入英国人手中时，把她交给我们，
to the church, and I in my role as Bishop of Beauvais will try her for heresy, for sorcery, for conjuring up demons, basically for anything you want to mention. I can guarantee, because I know that she's a witch, that she will be convicted. And when she is convicted, then the coronation of the DoFat will be revealed to the world to have been a literally satanic fraud.
交给教会，我作为博韦主教将以异端、巫术、召唤恶魔的罪名审判她，基本上是你想要提到的任何罪名。我可以保证，因为我知道她是一个女巫，她会被定罪。当她被定罪时，王太子的加冕典礼将被向世界揭示为一场彻头彻尾的撒旦欺诈。
Just one quick point. Again, is this cynicism? Is this cynical policy? No, it's not cynicism at all. He genuinely, like, I think this is important to get across. to people, because I think there's a general perception that, oh, this was terribly manipulative and cynical, the trial of Joan and all this. But the English genuinely, genuinely sincerely think this woman quite clearly is a witch. Yes, and the French servants of the
只有一个简短的观点。再次，这是愤世嫉俗吗？这是愤世嫉俗的政策吗？不，这根本不是愤世嫉俗。他真诚地，像，我认为这很重要，要传达给人们。因为我认为有一种普遍的看法，哦，这太具有操纵性和愤世嫉俗了，对琼的审判等等。但英国人真诚地、真诚地认为这个女人很明显是一个女巫。是的，兰开斯特政权的法国仆人也这么认为。好的。当然，我的意思是，这种信念与保护他们承诺服务的政权的愿望交织在一起。我的意思是，毫无疑问。但完全有可能相信你自己的利益和上帝的利益是一回事。我很高兴我们证明了英国人的真诚。让我们继续。所以这让贝德福德觉得是一个绝妙的计划。基本上，每个人都是赢家。
Lancasterian regime think that as well. Okay. Of course, I mean, that conviction is interfused with a desire to preserve the regime that they have committed themselves to serving. I mean, there's no question about that. But it's perfectly possible to believe that your own interests and the interests of God are one and the same. I'm glad that we've proved the sincerity of English. Let's continue. So this strikes Bedford as a brilliant plan. Basically, everyone's a winner.
卢森堡的约翰将得到他的钱。英国人将得到那个对他们的事业造成如此致命伤害的女巫。而博韦主教有机会通过摆脱一个女巫来侍奉他的上帝。太棒了。每个人都赢了。当然，唯一没有赢的人，
John of Luxembourg is going to get his money. The English are going to get their hands on the witch who has done their cause such lethal harm. And the Bishop of Beauvais has the opportunity to serve the Lord his God by getting rid of a witch. Brilliant. Everyone wins. The only person who doesn't win, of course,
是琼，当她被告知她将被卖给英国人时，她从卢森堡的约翰关押她的60英尺高的塔楼的窗户跳了下去。哦，我的上帝。60英尺。我知道这太不可思议了。不知何故，她在坠落中幸存了下来。我的意思是，一定有什么东西缓冲了它。
is Joan and she, when she is informed that she is going to be sold to the English, hurls herself from the window of the 60-foot tower in which John of Luxembourg has been keeping her. Oh my God. 60 feet. I know it's incredible. Somehow she survives the fall. I mean, something must have broken it.
但她脑震荡非常严重。我想她伤到了肝脏。她显然受了重伤。所以她需要时间来恢复健康。但是，你知道，交易已经完成了。所以贝德福德可以想，太棒了。现在我们终于有了一个计划。所以到了七月，诺曼底的局势已经足够稳定，亨利六世现在可以从加莱前往鲁昂。而鲁昂，此时是诺曼底的主要城市，嗯，它实际上是英国政权的某种
But she's very badly concussed. I think she does damage to her liver. She's obviously badly injured. And so it takes time for her to be nursed back to health. But, you know, the deal has been. done. And so Bedford can think, brilliant. Now at last we have a plan. So by July, sufficiency in Normandy have sufficiently stabilized that Henry the 6th can now process from Calais to Ruon. And Ruon, which is the leading city in Normandy, by this point, well, it is effectively the kind of
绿区。它是绝对安全的地方。它是兰开斯特的据点。所以亨利到达那里，贝德福德和兰开斯特政权可以确信他在那里是安全可靠的。然后九月，琼被卢森堡的约翰正式移交给英国人。他得到了巨额报酬。他对此非常高兴。那年十一月，琼被带到塞纳河口的一座堡垒，同时招募了一支军事护卫队护送她去鲁昂。最后，在12月23日，也就是圣诞节前夕，她在非常严密的
the green zone for the English regime. It's the place that is absolutely secure. It is the Lankastrian stronghold. And so Henry arrives there and Bedford and the Lancasterian regime can be confident that he is safe and secure there. Then in September, Joan is formally delivered by John of Luxembourg to the English. He gets a massive payment. He's very happy about that. That November, Joan is taken to a fortress in the mouth of the Sen while a military escort is recruited to escort her to Rouen. And finally, on the 23rd of December, so just before Christmas, she's under very heavy
看守下，戴着沉重的锁链，被带进鲁昂的城门，这是一座她注定永远无法离开的城市，因为多米尼克，她活不到半年了。对。好吧，只剩下一集来完成圣女贞德的故事了。如果你真的等不及了，就像我等不及一样，那么如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以听到那一集。如果你不是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员
guard, she's loaded down with chains, she is brought through the gates into Rouen, a city she is destined, never to leave, because Dominic, she has less than half a year to live. Right. Well, just one episode to go to complete the story of Jonah Bark. And if you really can't wait, as I can't wait, then if you're a member of the Restus History Club, you can hear that episode right now. If you're not a member The Rest is History Club
并且想加入并体验其所有不可思议的好处，那么请前往therestis-history.com。但这是一个多么大的悬念啊。还剩一集。汤姆，谢谢。再见。
and would like to join and to sample all of its incredible benefits, then head to the rest ishistory.com. But what a cliffhanger. One episode to go. Tom, merci. Au-voa.
再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。